Tổng thống Mỹ đơn em trong đặc quy định tạm hóan kế hoạch tấn công quân sự nhằm vào Irran và vũ trở,
chừng bất cả những nước lượng ngoại săng gia tăng từ dưới của gia Trung Đông và các đồng minh của Washington.
Theo con gồn tín của tế, ở lập sế út cơ tà và ủng em đã điện đam khẩn cấp với Mỹ,
đến nghĩa tạo thêm thời gian để tế ra thế giện như bức đi kìm chế, nhằm chẳng nào thang xuống đột.
Một đồng minh thân cậm của Mỹ, thu hưởng ísRL, bây giờ mình nên tàn cho hồ của mày tỏ lo ngại,
khả năng sử dạ các đồng trả đủ ở nếu Mỹ đến hành động của sử.
Trong bối kệng đó, ngày 6 tháng 1, Irran cộng bố không có kế hoạch thì hành án từ hành,
đối với những người thăm xa bởi tên đưa xem là tính hiệu hạ nhỉ căng thẳng.
Tuyvệ nhạy chẳng như mạnh, vẫn suy chỉ lập trường gướng giám và cạnh báo,
sẽ có biển phát mạnh nếu bạo lực tiếp sĩnh.
Các cuộc ra khá cú cơ gọi các biên tìm chế,
cho mối cạnh lóng ngại xin lộn của thịt ở động tư cửa tế ăn đi khu vực,
và tịt chân lập bằng câu.